let me focus on the issues that I think
bread or butter issues that impact
everybody I want to know if you get
elected president how fast you're going
to be able to fix our borders bring us
back to energy Independence how quickly
you might be able to work to change the
school system bring back Law and Order
and Safety and Security to this country
and every town and every city because I
think people need that if they want to
pursue happiness how quickly can you can
you shift gears and move this country I
think very quickly let me just say so I
heard the Sanctus saying oh well I get
eight years I get eight years he gets
four
you don't need four and you don't need
eight you need six months within six
months I said
within six months this can be done
other than other than you don't need
eight years and frankly I wouldn't vote
for him because he said you need eight
years you need six months we're going to
drill we're going to get our energy down
when the energy comes down other things
come down
and we're going to take care of things
we're going to immediately close up the
Border we had we had the greatest border
with the safest Border in the history of
our country now we have the worst Border
in the history of the world there's no
and I say this during rallies we love
our rallies but I say it dude there's
never been a third world country that
allowed people to pour into a they'd
stand there with sticks and stones if
they had to what's happening to our
country but in terms of doing it you
don't need eight years and you don't
need four years we can have a lot of it
done because these guys are amazing to
go guys they will be in fact I had it so
low that we had to raise it or they
would have all been out of business we
had so much oil we didn't know what to
do with it we bought a lot of it for
very little for the Strategic National
reserves that he then took to keep the
prices down before an election you know
we had the Strategic National reserves
almost full and then Biden came along
and took it to keep prices down or it's
called artificially down and the thing
is almost empty now and that's meant for
times of War it's not meant to keep a
price down for an automobile it's meant
for war for real problems and we had it
75 think of it 75 million barrels and I
bought it for peanuts and Congress I had
a fight Congress and the pricing was so
crazy and so good and we needed a place
because we had so much so we started
filling up this guy comes along and he
takes it for automobiles for people so
they before the election so the price
could give down now it's totally empty
it's it's the emptiest I think it's been
in 50 years and it's so sad and by the
way the price is still very high I don't
think gas went over three dollars a
gallon if I'm not mistaken when you were
when you were president as an average we
had it down to a dollar eighty seven we
actually had a little period of time
where we had it we had it load
Ed at lower sir
but the energy companies were the oil
companies weren't going to last we had
to say I said wait a minute I love it in
one way but in another way they're all
going to go bust we've got to get it up
a little bit but we added down to 1.87
but we had a period of time where it was
much lower than that it was too low
actually so we have we we have that's a
good Problem by the way that's a much
better problem than it said six dollars
and seven and eight and nine hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else